-The criminal contempt trial
of top Trump ally
Steve Bannon began today
after he refused to cooperate
with the committee
investigating the January 6th
insurrection.
The committee also revealed
that Trump had personally
attempted to contact a witness
in the investigation.
Despite all that,
top Republicans
are still sticking by Trump
as he signals that he's likely
to run again in 2024.
And on top of all that,
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin once again
torpedoed the Democrat's
domestic agenda in Congress.
For more on this, it's time
for a new segment we call
"Well, That All Sounds
Like a Bummer!"
♪♪
Oh, wait, I forgot. We already
have a segment like that.
It's called "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm sorry, it's just we have
been off for two weeks
and I totally forgot
how the show works.
Anyway, things have not
exactly been going great
for Joe Biden
and the Democrats lately.
Prominent Democrats,
both outside
and inside the White House,
have criticized Biden's
slow response
to the Supreme Court's decision
to overturn Roe v. Wade.
Serial rug puller Joe Manchin
once again
doomed any hope for
addressing climate change
or passing Biden's
domestic agenda.
And several prominent Democrats
have also expressed
frustration at Biden
for traveling to Saudi Arabia,
where he fist-bumped
a murderous tyrant.
Now, I know you did that
because you didn't want
to be seen shaking his hand,
but a fist bump is way worse.
At least with a handshake,
you might think, "Well,
it's two world leaders,
like it or not,
so that's standard enough."
But a fist bump makes it look
like you just hit a homerun
in the company softball game.
"Hey, nice one, MBS.
I think this is the year
we're finally going to beat
Dave's Heating and Cooling."
Once again,
as we have said before,
this is a good reminder
that it would be great
if we could generate
our own renewable energy
here at home
through wind and solar
so we don't have to be beholden
to these autocratic
petrostates.
In fact, I would love
to never have to say
the words autocratic petrostates
ever again.
Mainly because Wally thinks it's
too long to put on cue cards.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, they love Wally.
[ Laughter ]
Again, the Democrats
are in a funk right now,
which is bad
because whatever their flaws,
they are, at the moment,
the only thing
standing between America
and a monstrous gang
of radical seditionist
and potato-shaped goblins
in the Republican Party
who are actively attempting
to dismantle democracy
and impose
an authoritarian theocracy.
Really? You're making me
do autocratic petrostates
and authoritarian theocracy
in the same "Closer Look"?
What do you think I was doing
during my two weeks off,
vocal warm-ups?
An authoritarian theocracy
where abortion and
same-sex marriage are banned,
guns are everywhere,
and the only books kids
are allowed to read
in school classrooms
are illustrated copies
of "The Art of the Deal."
The drawings were done
by Trump himself,
which is why
they're all in Sharpie.
Oh, and...
[ Laughter ]
...the official drink of
the US government
from now on will be
a Diet Dr Pepper,
thanks to seditionist
and coup plotter Sidney Powell,
who was chugging them
during a deposition
she gave to the January 6th
Committee that aired last week.
-Among the people you saw there
was attorney Sidney Powell.
She was the one swigging
the Dr Pepper.
Actually, I think
it was Diet Dr Pepper.
-In the short period of time
that you had with the President,
did he seem receptive
to the presentation
that you were making?
-She -- She slugged that soda
like she's playing quarters
at a Christian sleepaway camp.
I will say it's a fitting drink
for her
because Diet Dr Pepper
is the soda you have
when there's nothing else left
in the vending machine,
just like Sidney Powell
is your attorney
when there's nothing else left
at the lawyer store.
Second, kudos to the editor
who put that clip together
and let it trail off
long enough for her
to take a giant gulp
of Diet Dr Pepper
after she finished her sentence.
Watching her chug a can
of Diet Dr Pepper
was another reminder
that she shouldn't be trusted.
It's like if your doctor
recommended surgery,
then put an entire bag
of Big League Chew in his mouth,
you'd get a second opinion.
I'd love to see the extended
cut of that clip.
5 hours later, it's probably
just her in the same shot
babbling about Hugo Chavez
smuggling in fake ballots
surrounded by a mountain
of empty Diet Dr Pepper cans.
[ Laughter ]
Also, side note here,
but when she was doing
press conferences
alleging voter fraud
and publicly
representing the President,
Sidney Powell looked like this.
When did she turn into
Grandma Saracen?
[ Laughter ]
Again, as a reminder,
we're a little rusty
from a two-week hiatus,
which is probably why
we decided earlier today
Matt Saracen's grandmother
from "Friday Night Light,"
it's definitely a reference
everyone will get.
[ Laughter ]
Just to give you a sense of how
long ago that show was on,
Tami Taylor is now a wealthy CFO
who takes fancy vacations.
Lyla Garrity is a mysterious
young mom in East Hyland,
and Landry Clarke
is married to Kirsten Dunst.
Way to go, Landry.
You were always my favorite.
Where were we?
Somewhere fun, I hope.
Ugh, Sidney Powell.
Also, when did Diet Dr Pepper
become the preferred beverage of
unhinged pro-coup Republicans?
A couple of months ago,
Sarah Palin,
who is now running
for Congress in Alaska,
was talking about
how she'd react to the media
on Capitol Hill if she wins,
and she said this...
-I anticipate that when I walk
down that hall to get
my Diet Dr Pepper,
sure,
the jackals are gonna be there
doing their jackal-ing.
-Man, terrible branding
for Diet Dr Pepper.
[ Laughter ]
This is the worst thing
to happen to a soft drink
since that photo emerged
of Mussolini drinking a Fanta.
[ Laughter ]
"Bad news, yeah.
Sidney Powell was drinking a
Dr Pepper during the hearings."
"Well, could you tell it
was a Dr Pepper?"
"Yeah, she had the label out."
So the only thing stopping
these nut jobs
from retaking power
is the Democratic Party,
which at the moment
is not a comforting thought.
Virtually their entire
domestic agenda in Congress
has been repeatedly
stymied by Joe Manchin,
who just doomed a compromise
of a compromise of a bill
he originally said
he would support last year,
even though he is the one
who came up
with the latest version of the
compromise in the first place.
And his fellow Democrats
are justifiably furious at him.
As Senator Bernie Sanders
made clear on Sunday,
without even letting the anchor
finish the question.
-I want to
turn to Congress
and the -- and the agenda there.
Senator Joe Manchin,
of course,
abruptly pulled the plug
this week on the Democ--
-No, Martha,
he didn't abruptly --
Martha --
-Okay, okay, let --
He abruptly on Friday.
-He didn't abruptly do anything.
-He was negotiating for a while.
-He sabotaged
the President's agenda.
No.
Look, if you check the record,
six months ago,
I made it clear that you have
people like Manchin,
Sinema to a lesser degree,
who are intentionally sabotaging
the President's agenda,
what the American people want,
what a majority of us
in the Democratic caucus want.
Nothing new about this.
-But Manchin says his main goal
is to do
what's good for West Virginia,
and he's worried
about inflation.
Listen to what he told me.
-Really, really.
[ Laughter ]
-I love how impatient Bernie is.
I'll bet he can't even sit
through the previews
at the movie theater.
"What the hell is this?
I came to see the Minions
perform their delightful antics.
I have no --
I have no interest
in what's coming out
next summer.
If I don't hear some giggling
and nonsense words right now,
I'm walking out."
But Bernie is right
to be pissed.
Who's not pissed?
The fate about the planet
and American democracy
rest in the balance.
And one fossil fuel millionaire
is standing in the way.
Democrats in Congress are trying
to get something, anything done.
Meanwhile, Republicans are fully
embracing the authoritarianism
that fueled Trump's rise
and led to the coup attempt
on January 6th,
even as the committee
investigating the coup
accumulates more
and more evidence
that Trump and his cronies
committed various crimes.
Trump gave his strongest signal
yet last week
that he's going to run
again in 2024,
and Republicans are still
sticking by him.
On Sunday,
the governor of Arizona,
who has been repeatedly
attacked by Trump and once said
Trump bears some responsibility
for January 6th,
still refused
to rule out backing Trump
if he runs in 2024.
-You told me last year
on this show
that Donald Trump bears some
responsibility for January 6th.
Do you believe his actions
on January 6th or inaction
should disqualify him
from holding public office
in the future?
-Dana, I condemned January 6th,
and I think everyone
that broke the law
should be held accountable.
In our system,
this is up to the voters
on what happens next?
-If Donald Trump runs in 2024,
will you support him?
-I think we will have options
in the 2024 primary race.
I am hopeful
we will have options,
and I want somebody who can win
that general election
because I believe
with success in 2022,
the general election
is the Republican Party's
for the taking.
-"I think we will have options.
I am hopeful
we will have options.
But if not,
I will get down on all fours
and crawl like a dog
to beg for Trump's forgiveness
because I am
a spineless coward."
Should we maybe get Bernie
back out here
to yell about the Minions again?
That was fun.
"We need to tax Gru
and make him pay
his fair share.
The Minions need to unionize."
[ Laughter ]
There is nothing Donald Trump
could do
to lose the support
of these craven dopes.
In fact, just today,
one of Trump's closest allies
and a key figure
in the attempted coup,
Steve Bannon,
who was caught on tape
admitting just days
before the election
that Trump would declare victory
even if he lost,
went on trial
for contempt of Congress.
Jury selection
for Bannon's trial began today.
-Jury selection will begin
in the trial
of Trump confidant Steve Bannon.
He is facing
criminal contempt charges
for refusing to obey a subpoena
from the January 6th committee.
-Now, this is not going to be
your typical jury selection
because most or all
of the jurors
will have heard of Steve Bannon
or the committee.
But the goal
is not to get jurors
who've never heard of anybody.
The goal is to get jurors
who can be fair and impartial.
-I'm sorry, but even if you've
never heard of Steve Bannon,
how could you look at this guy
and be fair and impartial?
Even if I had no idea
who he was,
I'd take one look at him
and assume at best
he'd been arrested
for stealing a seaplane
in the Florida Keys
or maybe illegally
selling soft drinks
on the sidewalk in Times Square.
"Hey, psst.
Want a taste of the Pep?
Want a little --
a little pep in your step
Don't go and pay
those bodega prices.
Bet a little pep
in your step."
[ Laughter ]
Also, if you're thinking
to yourself,
"Wait, wasn't Steve Bannon
already arrested
for a different crime?"
The answer is yes,
he was charged
with defrauding Trump supporters
as part of a scam fundraiser
to build the wall
and was arrested on a fugitive
Chinese billionaire's yacht
by Postal Service cops
before Trump pardoned him.
Yet another series of words
that is both insane
and will be mostly forgotten
to history
because too much other
crazy [bleep] has happened.
That would be like reading
a history book
and finding out that
for a little while
in his early 20s,
Abraham Lincoln switched
from stovepipe hats to fedoras.
"They call me Abe,
and if I'm being honest,
I love
the Squirrel Nut Zippers."
[ Laughter ]
You know, I burned Sal earlier
because he referenced
"Friday Night Lights,"
and I was -- said
that was really dated.
And then I put in
the Squirrel Nut Zipper joke.
[ Laughter ]
So I guess I'm the one
who got burned.
[ Laughter ]
Bannon's trial and the
revelations about his role
in the attempted coup
are happening
as the January 6th hearings
build toward
what could very well be
a shocking conclusion,
even after all the shocking
revelations we've already seen
about Trump's obvious
criminal liability.
On top of everything else,
last week, the committee
also announced
that Trump had personally
attempted to tamper
with one of the witnesses.
-After our last hearing,
President Trump tried to call
a witness in our investigation.
A witness you have not yet seen
in these hearings.
That person declined
to answer or respond
to President Trump's call
and instead alerted
their lawyer to the call.
Their lawyer alerted us.
And this committee has supplied
that information
to the Department of Justice.
Let me say one more time
we will take any effort
to influence witness testimony
very seriously.
-I'll admit, before they started
this whole thing,
I was afraid these hearings
would be boring,
and instead, we've got
Liz Cheney doing teases
like she's Robert Stack
in "Unsolved Mysteries."
"The President
of the United States
places a phone call,
but for what purpose?
The answer to that question
and more next week
on the January 6th hearings."
I do enjoy imagining Trump
trying to get through
to a witness
because you know
he's dumb enough
to leave a voicemail message.
And you know it was probably
like an hour long.
"Hey, Mark,
this is your friend Donald.
Just calling to remind you
how much I appreciate
your loyalty. I like you, Mark.
I like you a lot more
than those nasty windmills.
Windmills, they gave you cancer
and they kill your birds.
Birds, we love the birds.
We love birds, don't we, Mark?
The birds, they soar through
the skies majestically.
It's truly a miracle of nature.
I would love to be free
as a bird,
but instead I remain
shackled here on earth,
entangled.
I'm en-- Mark,
I'm entangled, Mark.
Mark, I'm entangled
in this web of deceit
I've weaved for myself.
Or is it woven?
I never know if it's weaved
or it's woven, Mark.
I say weaved,
and I think it's woven.
I say woven.
I think it's weaved.
I'm always going to stumble
on grammar, Mark. You know that.
But the point is, Mark,
oh, to be a bird.
I --"
-Mailbox full. Goodbye.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The Republican Party
has fully descended
into authoritarianism
and they're on the precipice
of retaking power
and dismantling our democracy,
which is why Democrats
must do everything possible
to stop them,
not to mention addressing
a bunch of other urgent issues
like climate change
for many reasons.
We need to move
past fossil fuels.
Hell, maybe we can make cars
that run on...
-Diet Dr Pepper.
[ Theme music plays ]
We're all --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're all a little rusty.
That -- You're not supposed
to hear that song yet.
Just pretend like you
didn't hear the end of this.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million meals
a year to men,
women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.